après une première tentative début
février le gouvernement indien
renouvelle ses voeux au réseau social
twitter bloqué quelques 250 compte ou
tweed utilisateurs indiens qui
représenterait une grave menace pour
l'ordre public
parmi eux des militants des
représentants syndicaux du monde de
l'agriculture ou encore des leaders de
l'opposition
et si twitter s'est montré réticent en
suspendant quelques comptes le 1er
février puis en les débloquant quelques
heures plus tard cette fois
narendra modi le premier ministre n'a
pas hésité à menacer la plateforme
américaine de poursuites pénales allant
jusqu'à l'éventuel emprisonnement
d'employés locaux
ce mercredi twitter a indiqué avoir
suspendu de façon permanente plusieurs
comptes et d'autres seulement en inde
pourtant l'incertitude demeure nous ne
croyons pas que les actions qui ont été
ordonnées et est conforme à la loi
indienne
conformément à nos principes de défense
de liberté d'expression nous n'avons
pris aucune mesure à l'encontre de
comptes constitué d'entités médiatique
deux journalistes de militants et de
politiciens nous pensons qu'agir comme
exigé violerait leur droit fondamental
de liberté d'expression en vertu de la
loi indienne et si twitter s'est immiscé
dans le bras de fer qui oppose
gouvernement est agriculteur depuis le
mois de novembre
c'est parce que les manifestants contre
les réformes agricoles unifient leurs
forces sur le réseau social
jusqu'à interpellé deux icônes mondiales
la chanteuse rihanna et la militante
greta sonberg
un espoir pour cet habitant puisqu'il
s'agissait de l'une des plus grandes
manifestations pacifiques jamais
organisé depuis des décennies il fallait
absolument qu'elle attire l'attention
d'un public international comme vous
pouvez le constater lorsque le
gouvernement indien a tenté de couper
internet l'électricité et
l'approvisionnement en eau le public
international s'est réveillé
et a décidé qu'il devait maintenant
parler de la détresse permanente à
laquelle les agriculteurs sont
confrontés
lo ng international reporters sans
frontières a qualifié ces suspensions de
compte deux cas choquants de censure
manifeste et si l'inde est souvent
présentée comme la plus grande
démocratie au monde selon reporter sans
frontières le pays se place seulement au
142e rang sur 180 du classement de la
liberté de la presse en 2020